what did you know and learn at the end  of your career  that you wish you knew at the beginning  um  understanding empathy and compassion  because as a young kid when i came in  the league it was like i'm driving this  way  and either you're going to be on the  train or be on the track  right where there was no such thing as  understanding that people have lives  outside of the game  which apparently i did not um  but like if i understood at an early age  it helps me as a leader to communicate  better  i came to understand that later  [Music]  and getting to know people on a personal  level  what are their fears where their  insecurities  where their dreams and ambitions desires  those sorts of things  you come to understand that about a  person you can help them  reach the best version of themselves